CONTENTION.
HERE WE GO AT PRUDENTIAL CENTER.
COZENS GATHERS A LOOSE PUCK OVER
THE DEVILS LINE
THOMPSON.
DIDN'T GET IT ALL TH
>> Steve: SOME BELIEVE HIS IN T.
SKINNER CAN SCOREVEL ZACHA.
GOOD TO SEE RYAN T PASSING PLAY
CAUGHT UP IN HIS SLUMP.
>> Steve:
ANDERSON.
LOOKS LIKE HE'S OKPOSO.
HAMILTON. SHOT.
NICE JOB BY RYAN GRAVES TO KICK
THE PUCK IN.
CENTERING DRIVE IN FRONT FOROR
PUTS HIMSELF IN THE RIGHT AREA.
LOOK
GOOD FORE-CHECK BY THE DEVILS TO
FORCE THAT
1:07. TO HAPPEN.
LOOK, HE'S BEEN .
HERE'S A CHANCE BY OL LOVE SON.
SAVED BYAVE HERE.
TUCH JUST RIFLES IT TOWARDS THE
NET ON THE BACKHAND ON THE UP
PENALTY. A SHOT.
BROKE HIS STICK IN THE PUCK AS S
JERSEY.
THE DEVILS JUST GETD.
HERE COMES MICHAEL McLEOD. FORE.
McLEOD, STEAL THAT LANE.
NEARLY PICKED OFF BY POWER.
TAKEN BYTHEY SCORE! ATTACK.
SCORES HIS FIRST NATIONAL HOCKEY
LEAGUE GOAL.
THAT'S A HECK O O COME
IN FOR THE SECOND TIME IN A
CARELESS.GRAVES.
>> Ken: COZENS HAS THOMPSON.
ACROSS.
SKINNER WITH THE FINISH.BACKHAND